BOMANI JONES:
All right, here it is.
Flopping...
the most Karen shit
in all of sports.
All right, so, think about it.
What does a Karen do?
Lie about being attacked,
pretend something happened
that did not,
then try to get the authorities
on her side.
I guess being a Karen
is not
the exclusive territory
of the White woman.
Your favorite athlete hits
the ground like he got shot,
even though nobody touched him,
he's doing the same thing!
So, if you falsely accuse
somebody of fouling you,
you should go to jail for that!
Or be suspended.
Free the weed man.
Lock up the flopper.
Preach.
In our day, taking a charge
was honored.
What do you mean, "our day"?
NARRATOR: Game Theory.
Sunday nights.
Do you want me to fill this in?
Hey, I need help at the front.